Presentation
Savior what mortal  can touch the beauty of this book of Hebrews without ruining it Lord.
We are incapable of touching a book so awesome, so precious, with a message directly from your heart Lord.
I beg you Lord, that during this days that you maybe are our teacher, that you may break us the Bread of Life.
Open our eyes and our spirits  that we may see the glory of your face that shines through This message of Hebrews.
Open our hearts to the revelation in your beauty that is here;
That we may never again walk in the same manner Lord.
Oh plant in the deepest of our heart the beauties, the truths and the glory that is here Lord.
That is they may never be forgotten, Oh Lord roots these truths in our hearts.
Oh Savior, that allways in the valley of the shadow of death we may have the grace to return to the beauty revealed here Lord.
Jesus Christ we are waiting in you, trusting in you, Oh Master of Galilee,  teach us please.
Lord in The name of your precious Son, we ask you, we beg you, thanking you.
For the crumbs from your table, thank you Lord.